ありがとうございますありがとうございます
矢野と申します本日はよろしくお願い致します先ほどアイスブレイクで話させて
いただいた方が高校生ということですね
本当に今日はいろんな方々が来ていただいているのかなと思います
じゃあ今日あの僕がですね話させていただきたいことこれからの街のあり方について
ちょっと考えているんですね
そんなアイディアちょっとシェアさせてください
まず自己紹介へこれちょっと僕なんですねあのオランダに小さい頃9年間くらい進んで
てこんな金髪のすごい美男所の中にアジア系キと言ういるとなかなかこう溶け込むのに
苦労した思い出があったんですね
それ以外にも僕は a 高校がアメリカで大学はカナダで技術で働いてたりとかしまし
た
日本に戻ってきた妹してなかなかコミュニティに溶け込めない引越しをするためにその
街に溶け込めないということが僕の
ちょっと苦労でしたね出そう高校生の時にまあそのアメリカ
れなかなか街に溶け込めないときに出会ったこの街並みの美学って言う
まあ少し小難しい本で僕は全然わかんなかったんですけどこの1ページだけ
止まりまして piazza って言う
イタリアにはピアットという保守の中に広場があってその中で様々な人が交流して
コミュニティを作っているこんな空間があるということをあのあったんですねこれかと
しかがグローバルでどんどん増えていく中でこう言った
都市空間が必要なんじゃないかと思ったわけです
でそれでこ
目指してですねあの土木工学と都市設計おこう
真面目に勉強してたんですね成績もよくあって全部ですね
ジェネコンとかデベロッパーにぜひ昼食してまちづくりに携わりたいと思ったんです
けれども
結果どうだったかっていうと全部落ちたんですね誰を僕を雇ってくれないんですよ
こんなに
ね思えもあるのに誰も雇ってくれないえーまぁ
じゃあ実際にまちづくりができないならそれに紐づく
大きなやっぱりお金が動くのでちゃファイナンスの領域で働いていました
でそこから何年か過ぎて
家族もできてそれで子供の2人目が生まれたときにですね
あのちょっとした事故にあったんですねこれは私は2人目の息子なんですけど
1か月後に実際事故に遭いましたちょっとこの写真見るとねあのー
ちょっと重いと土間とかあるんですけれどももう歩けないかも知る
しないと言われたんですね
でも大丈夫です彼も今元気にこう歩いてるので暗い暗子でよかったんですけれども
その時に冠したものがやはりこと私たちもあの引っ越してきたばかりだったので
なかなかこう誰にも知り合い6味頼る人もいないし
孤独を感じて過ごしてましたとそのある日柱をなじま
車の駐輪所であの
最近がか知らないし彼の名前を知らない方だったんですけれども
最近なんか高原来ないですね大丈夫ですかって言われたんですね
大丈夫ですか何が解決もないんですけれどもその一言に僕はすごく心を救われました
これだけ it が発達しているのになぜ僕は近くの人
近くの情報というのこへ滝知らなかったんだろうということに気づいていったんですね
人生にはまあ室も助ける
特に近くの人の助けが必要になる大めぐっては必ず訪れますそれこそだてだった今
介護だったり可能だったりいろんなでだああいう子の債務そうですね
人の助けて必ず必要になってくる
でそれに対してはつながりってすごく大事だよねって色々調べたらまあいろんな文献出
てくるわけです
でまぁこれが一つなんですけれども長生きする要因として
タバコを吸うとかあのお酒を飲むとか運動するよりもつながりがたくさんあったほうが
長生きするというような研究がこれはれます
まーたツナが入ってすごく大事なんだ者でも今で日本の中でご近所づきあいとかそう
いったものってあるのかなと
でこれは内閣府の調べで
地域の中で助け合える人の数っていうアンケートがあったんですね
これが4人噛んで堪えたのが94%ほぼほぼ皆無なんです
ホブ地域を繋がってないですね
で確かに私の感覚でもそんな感じだと思います
それに対するでまたアンケートが出ていてこれ厚生労働省が出してたものなんです
けれども
ご近所付き合いが盛んであってほしいかとか近所付き合いの理想論みたいなをとった
アンケートだったんですねこれは驚いたことに
ご近所付き合いが盛んであってほしいということ
大たのが80%ことが肥えているわけです
意外だったのが20代から60代まですべての年齢層でこういったことを求めてところ
ちょっと意外でしたね
じゃあつながりってすごく大事だけれども今はない
でも実は皆さん欲しいと思っているこの現実をやっぱり高い
していかなくてはいけないなと思ったんです
でその時にへまぁ以前僕は十分の頃に読んだこのコーンをやっぱ思い出してですね
町にはこういったあの広場が必要だろう
で街の中でも広がる広場でも
あてですねそこに人が集まって情報があふれる
そんな広場が必要だとで僕も通りサラリーマンだったので自分に広場を作るということ
はなかなか難しかったと
なのでじゃあ女に作ってみましょうということで始めてみました
でへ
事業としてはこういうあの地域 sns みたいにフェイスブックのローカル版みたい
なやっていて近所の方々が色々やり取りをしてます例えば子供の熱が39点与党
39で5分あってどっかいいじゃありませんかって投稿すると
4風後にはもういろんな方々からあの4人のママから具体的
アドバイスがあったよとかそれ以外にもこういう近所のリユースですね
ひな人形とかそう言って影とかパンパースとかですねもあります
こういった行政の方々も今サービスを使っているとええまあとはいえこのアプリを使っ
てたんですけどなかなかこう
これでいいのかなっていうところがですねこれ以上何だからか
低下してなかったんですねそれに対してやはりへリアルなことが大事などということで
実際に中央区で子育て支援施設みたいな終え運営しております
でそういうしていく中で実はリアルとデジタルの相関が少しずつ見えてきたんですね
それがあるサンプルをとってみたんですけれども
オンラインでイベントを知ってイベントを参加した人人の
翌月のログインにすっていうのは前月ログイン日数に対して3倍曲がっていることが
わかったんです
そうするとじゃあ3倍もその色ログインしていってことは3倍もいろんな情報が集め
られたりとかちょっとつながったりだとかまた新しいイベントの情報失態だとそうする
ことで渡り合うでつながっていく
今後スパイラルができること
気づいたんですねコミュニティのはオンラインだけでもなくリアルだけではなく両方で
作ってくるのだ
まあこういうことをあの分かってきたと実際に今ここの中央区
340代にも3割が使っているこういった新しいご近所のコミュニティのあり方です
でもこれでもあのまだ課題があったんです
でこれを進めていく中じゃあコミュニティできましたと
じゃあもう一つ課題はじゃあ今日ってバズワードで何がいいんだか悪いんだかわかん
ないんです
でそれをこうなんとか可視化していかなくてはいけないでそれはそのユーザー
ユーザー数なのか pv 数なのか東コースなこれも違うなと
こういった繋がり t の
ちゃんと見える化していかなくてはいけないと
でこれを一コミュニティを評価できないっていうことはすごく
課題で評価できない=その上にビジネスが乗らないんですね
ビジネスが乗らない頃市場もないわけです
これだけコミュニティとかつながりが大事だってこの世の中にちゃんと評価しないと
こうやったマーケットすらない
これ
やっぱり解決しなくてはいけない
でそれで行き着いた私にはの社会実験としてやっているのが街のあのユーザーさんの
つながりの数っていうのを拾って言ってコミュニティバリューという独自の指標を作っ
て
町のコミュニティがどれだけ活性化しているかということを
数値化可視化しようとしています
概念としては個人のソーシャルキャピタルまあこれは厚生労働省いたされているものな
んですけれども3つを
項目がありますこう県産加工圏ネットワークですねそれを個人のユーザーさんの
アクションでですねその紐づいてモデルに組み込んで一人ずつのコミュニティバリが
出来てその1人ずつのコミュニティ針を集積していったものが街の国てぃ倍となって
いく
これは思想としては街は人で成り立っているという思想を数式業としてますで結果
こんな感じでですね
あのまあ
家ごとにグラフ化されて盛り上がっているところもあれば
平井平たいところもあったりだとか遊具見える化ができています
まるで株価で僕たち通常会社を評価を発していますけれども
そう言うとそのような形で一つは物差しとしてですねこれが正しいとかでは一つの
物差しとしてコミュニティを図っ
ていくことを今チャレンジしています
でこれがこのサービスは日本が場所部でも7月に始めたのでこういった形でアン
どんどん口 bt がこの中でも作られていて現在1人当たりのユーザー33の
つながりをこの中では持っているような数字こんな
こんなあの数字が出てきますとで
じゃなかなかこ概念的に話してもわかりにくいので一人のでクック彼はさんっていう人
ですね
あのビジネスマンで4歳の子どもがいますと
抱いて30代で引越して子供ができたタイムで後くらいに引っ越してきたという方の
コミュニティバリューがこれですと上がってきてますねと
じゃあこれはフェーズ5
にブレークダウンしてたどうだったかとでまず最初アプリが入った時はこう
まずオンラインでご参加するんですねいいねしたりコメントしたりで
その後音なんで貢献していくんですね
自分のこの情報をシェアしたり横数字で表れてきます
そのうち次がへ
リアルなイベント
に誰かが取材しても参加していきます
これはあの街の子ばかりの確かボランティアグループなんですですけれどもそこにこう
入っていきますでエコれ直近ですね自分でそのボランティアグループを最近リアの運営
メンバーとしてな
こういう風な形で必ずしも1対1ではないんですけれども
相関関係の中で見えてきているということです
でこういったかあさんをはじめいろんな人とのコミュニティの活動が主的されて街の
コミュニティの価値となっております
これは今ムーブメントとしてへ
起きてきていることだと思います街のコミュニティで評価するということを
行政も
鳥導入して初めてこれを使ってですね事業 kpi として活用してその街の
コミュニティが
三島どれぐらい評価されている活性化してっていうのかというのを
これで見ております
でまぁこの活動のなかで見えてきたこと3つあります
デジタルっていうのはリアルなコミュニティをつくる導入戦であるということでそして
リアルとデジタルを組み合わせることでコミュニティーというのがどんどんどんどん
活性化するスピードが加速していく
そしてそれをしっかり数値化見える化することでこれをコミュニティした科学すること
ができるということですね
でこれが将来の
少し視点を変えて将来の街の価値観というのは今大きいダン
転換期にあると考えています今までは
街っていうのはたてもで通りだけ新しい建物かとか[ __ ]がいいとかそういったもので
図られてきた指標があります
でも今後は沈降が減っていくので
今まで以上にも建物は必要がなくなっていく
あの
e コマースさてデリバリーも進化しているので家にいてもサービスが受けられる
もっと言えば家からも働ける
本た環境があの子の次の a 10年だ
こっていきます
そうなっていくと祖父ハードからソフトに
町の価値が返還していくこういう風な考えを持っております
でこれからコミュニティっていうのが本当に大事になってパチの最も大事な資産になっ
てくると考えていてそれを実現させていくためにも
それをちゃんと評価するフレームワークをつくそうするとそのコミュニティを大事にし
たり
発展したいそういったプロジェクトがどんどん増えて
9それがちゃんと見えてくることによって継続することができ改善することができ
そして結果発展していく
こんな社会を私は目指しております
最後になりますけれども how せずメーカーターン
席実名貸席
ハウスメーカーターンせて前ずメイクと席
街の価値というのはみなさん1そう考えておりますありがとうございました
[拍手]